FEMALE SPEAKER:
I'm really, really
excited today to bring a friend
of mine and speaker, a author,
Mike Robbins, to Google
San Francisco to talk
about his latest book,
"Nothing Changes Until You Do."
This is Mike's third book.
He's also written two other
books that you may know,
"Focus On the Good
Stuff" and "Be Yourself,
Everyone Else is Already Taken."
So without further ado,
I'll introduce Mike Robbins.
Thank you.
MIKE ROBBINS: Thanks, Rachel.
All right, I think I
might come around here.
How many of you guys have ever
had like a goal or a dream
or something you really
wanted to have happen,
but you couldn't figure
out how to make it happen?
You've had that
experience, right?
You probably have certain
things in your life
like that right now.
I thought a good way
for me to get started
to talk a little
bit about this book
and what I'm going to
talk about here today
is actually tell a
little bit of my story.
Some of you may know that,
some of you on live stream
may know that as well, but also
sort of as it relates to some
of the core themes of this book.
But it's actually story related
to the first book that I wrote,
which is called "Focus
on the Good Stuff."
So as some of you know, my
background-- I grew up here
in the Bay Area, I played
baseball most of my life.
I actually got drafted right out
of high school by the Yankees.
Didn't end up signing
with the Yankees
because I got an opportunity
to play baseball at Stanford.
So I go to Stanford,
play there, then I
get drafted out of Stanford
by the Kansas City Royals,
signed a pro contract.
The way it works in professional
baseball here in the US,
some of you know, you sign a
pro contract with a major league
team, you still have to
go in the minor leagues.
I ended up injuring
my pitching arm
when I was in the minor
leagues with Kansas City,
so my career ended a lot
sooner than I wanted it to.
So that was an interesting
challenge that I went through.
But as I was kind of making it
my way through that process--
I had to get a job,
figure out what
I was going to do with the
rest of my life, right?
It was the late '90s.
I got a job working for
an internet company,
actually, not that
far from where
we're standing right here.
I worked for 24/7 Media.
Our biggest competitor was
DoubleClick at the time.
So I was in online
ad sales, actually.
Worked there for about
a year and a half.
Then I went to go get a job
at a sports website called
rivals.com, and it was
kind of a new startup
and a lot of VC backing.
We were all going to get rich,
it was going to go public.
And then the dot.com bubble
burst and I lost my job.
But I had this
idea-- and this had
been for a number of years--
that I really wanted to speak
and I wanted to
write and I wanted
to try to inspire people.
I didn't really
know how to do that,
but I got some encouragement
and I got some coaching,
and I decided at the
beginning of 2001,
even though I was nervous,
to start my own business
as a coach, as a speaker.
And one of the things
that I wanted to do,
and one of things I
figured you have to do
is write a book, right?
I mean, that's part
of how you do that.
So I decided I
wanted write a book.
And I didn't know anything
about writing a book,
but I started reading books
about how to write a book,
and I started meeting people
about how you do that.
And within not that long,
maybe about nine months,
a year, I had met a
guy who was helping me
and kind of coaching
me and putting together
a book proposal.
Because that's sort of what you
have to do to then get an agent
and then get a book deal, and I
was learning all these things.
OK, so I start to do this.
So then fast
forward, it literally
goes over the span
of about five years.
I go through two
literary agents.
I get rejected 25 times by
every publisher on the planet.
And I'm frustrated.
And now it's like
early 2006, I'm
on my second literary agent.
We've gone through all
these series of rejections.
And I'm frustrated.
And I've been speaking
now for a number of years,
and I've been working
with some cool companies
here in the Bay Area
and around the country.
And my agent says
to me, listen, Mike.
You're a nice guy.
I know you're really passionate
about this whole appreciation
thing.
But you know what, I don't
think it's going to work.
Maybe you gotta change the
topic, or I don't know,
but the publishers
aren't into it.
And I listened to
her on the phone.
This is like late
February, 2006.
My wife, Michelle, and I--
we live in the Bay Area now.
We live up in Marin.
We've lived here our whole life.
She's from here as well.
We had just had our
first daughter, Samantha,
who was a new baby,
who's now eight.
But Samantha had just been born.
So I have this conversation
with my agent on the phone,
and I listen to her feedback,
and I go to sleep that night.
But I'm pissed.
Like, I can't even sleep.
And I'm not necessarily mad at
her, I'm just mad in general.
And I don't know what
the anger is about.
And I'm talking to my wife and
she's trying to go to sleep,
and I can't sleep.
And then finally in the
middle of the night it hit me,
and I went, you know what?
I realize what's going on.
I keep waiting for permission.
I'm waiting for someone
to tell me I'm ready.
I don't know if it's my agent or
some publisher or some someone.
And I said, you know what?
I'm gonna write this book.
So I called her
the next day and I
said, listen, I
appreciate the feedback,
But I gotta tell you something.
I'm not waiting anymore.
I've been waiting
for your permission,
I've been waiting-- I'm
just not waiting anymore.
I'm going to write this book.
I'll publish it
myself if I have to.
That's what I'm going to do.
And she said, all right, Mike.
I understand you're frustrated.
Listen, she said,
before you do that, I've
got a couple other publishers
that I hadn't reached out
to yet.
Let me send it out
to all three of them
and see what they think.
She calls back two
days later and says,
you're not going
to believe this.
All three of them want it.
And I ended up publishing
my first book with Wiley.
And what was interesting about
it, because I looked at it--
and I remember thinking to
myself even at the time,
but especially now
looking back-- nothing
had changed with
my book proposal.
Quite frankly, I had literally
had the same proposal
for almost five years.
I mean, I had adjusted it
a little bit along the way.
It was the same thing.
The only thing that
changed was me.
Something shifted inside of me.
I got mad.
I don't know, I just
had a new daughter,
I don't know what it was,
but something shifted.
And now I can see, looking
back-- that was 2006,
I wrote the book, it came out
in '07-- I can see in hindsight
now, looking back,
oh, you know what?
I wasn't actually ready
up until that moment.
And the moment I was ready,
that's when it happened.
And you can probably
look in your own life
and see there's been a lot of
situations and circumstance
that happened just like that.
You can't always
tell in the moment.
You connect the dots when
you look back and go, oh,
that's why that happened.
So a lot of the focus of this
new book that I just wrote
is about that.
How do we shift internally?
What do we need to shift
and change internally
so that the world
around us changes?
But in addition to that,
it's also really about
that one of the core themes of
this book is self-compassion.
Self-compassion.
And I've been fascinated
by this and have
started to research
this a little bit.
It's been something that I've
both struggled with and found
interesting over the course of
most of my life and my work.
And especially
when I find myself
in environments
like here at Google
with a lot of really
smart, talented people,
I find that many of us
struggle with our relationship
with ourselves.
And how do we treat ourselves
with that sense of compassion?
So what I hope to do here
is to talk a little bit.
I'm going to share a few stories
from the book and a few ideas
related to
self-compassion and how
we can make some of
those internal shifts.
But I also hope-- and even
though I know some of you
are watching this
video or you're
watching us on live stream-- for
those of you here in the room,
that we have a
bit of a dialogue,
that I'll be able to
answer some questions.
But we'll talk about
this, how this relates
to you and to your life, so that
you can take some things away
that you can actually use.
Cool?
So take a moment right
now, if you would.
and if you're watching us on
live stream you can do this.
If you're by
yourself, maybe just
jot it down or think about it.
If you're watching
the video, same thing.
But for those of you here,
pair up with someone and talk
a little bit about for you,
thinking about--and I'll talk
a little more about
self-compassion-- but for you,
in terms of your
relationship with yourself,
what do you find makes it
difficult or challenging
for you to be kind and
compassionate to yourself?
Because I know for many
of us, myself included,
that can be challenging.
So what kind of
things do you find
get in the way of
your own ability
to be kind and
compassionate to yourself?
So pair up with someone and just
chat a little bit about that,
and then we'll dive into it.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MIKE ROBBINS: right.
So did everybody get a
chance to talk a little bit?
OK.
So let's talk a
little bit about this.
So what makes it
difficult, what makes it
challenging, if
you will, or what
gets in the way of us being kind
and compassionate to ourselves?
OK.
And I'll repeat this
for those of you
who are on live
stream and the video.
So you say if you're too
compassionate with yourself--
if you are-- then the fear is
that I won't achieve my goals,
right?
How many of you
can relate to that?
Yeah.
And look, this is a
really important one,
because so many of
us, myself included,
this is one of the places
where we really get stuck.
And we get trapped in
this idea of, like, oh,
if I'm too compassionate
with myself,
then I'm not going
to be focused,
I'm not going to
be driven, I'm not
going to get to the
next level, right?
Now look, we all gotta
figure this out on our own
and what works for
us and what doesn't
work and all that, right?
I have found in my life-- now
I'm 40 years old now, right?
So I've got a lot more
life to live, I hope.
But I've lived a
few years and what
I've learned over time
is that that fear,
that concern has been there.
And it was a lot stronger
for me as I was younger.
As I'm getting a little bit
older I'm starting to notice,
I'm not so sure
that's actually true.
And I think we buy
into that notion.
Culturally we buy
In environments, especially an
environment here like Google
where there's a lot of
really smart people,
there's a lot of really
ambitious people, this idea
that compassion is-- oh,
well then I'll be lazy,
well then I won't be so-- right?
And again, just as
a challenge to you--
but I appreciate you bringing
it up, but to all of us--
maybe it's not true that pushing
ourselves and driving ourselves
is actually what leads
us to being successful.
But that's definitely
a concern or a fear.
Well, like if I'm too easy
with myself or soft on myself,
right?
You know, I'll share a story
from the book related to that,
because I think it's
really important
and I think it's
so poignant here.
And as Rachel
mentioned, look, I've
spoken at 15 Google
offices around the world
over the last four years.
I've had a chance to work
with literally thousands
and thousands of Googlers.
So I'm not an expert
on your culture,
but I have some
perspective, right?
And also other companies
here in Silicon Valley
and other companies where
there are people like you,
gets the best and the
brightest, doing really well,
people-focused.
There's something-- so I went
to Stanford as an undergrad.
And the day that I showed
up on campus at Stanford--
some of you may have heard me
share this story because I talk
about it when I'm here
at Google especially--
was simultaneously one
of the most exciting
and one of the most
humbling days of my life.
Because not only-- Stanfor's
a really good school,
as you probably know,
right? --but not only
is Stanford a great
school, but it's
got a great baseball program.
And I played baseball.
I mean, that was my focus
as a kid growing up.
So to get an opportunity to
play baseball at Stanford
is literally the brass ring.
I mean, as a high
school baseball player,
if you're a decent student
and a decent baseball player,
you want to go to Stanford.
There are thousands of
kids across the country who
want to go.
I got in.
I was excited.
And my whole senior
year in high school
I was like, the guy
who got into Stanford.
I mean it was like a big deal.
I mean, this is like
my whole identity.
Then I show up on campus at
Stanford the very first day,
I'm all excited.
I get there and I
look around and I
went-- I had a very basic
but profound realization:
Oh, everybody else
got into Stanford too.
Like I wasn't so
special anymore.
And not only was I not
special, immediately
that little voice in
my head started saying,
dude, you don't belong here.
Dude, look how could he
is, look how smart she is.
And it wasn't just in baseball.
It was like all
the kids, everyone
seemed way smarter than me,
way more talented than me,
way more confident than me.
And I'm thinking, I
must have snuck in.
Like I'm sure
someone's literally
going to knock on my door and be
like, Robbins, come over here.
You gotta go.
Like that was the
feeling that I had.
Now what we call this
in psychological terms
is the impostor syndrome.
And what's important, and when
I write about it in the book,
I talk about, remember,
everybody experiences
that impostor
syndrome, everyone.
It does not matter how
talented anyone is.
accomplished they are.
Look, in some of
the work that I do
I'm always amazed when I
started to work with people
I meet, people
who are incredibly
accomplished, incredibly
talented, and just, wow.
You get down below,
as I like to say,
the water line of the
iceberg a little bit,
and they start sharing
what's really going on
and how they're really
feeling, oftentimes
there's an enormous
amount of insecurity,
an enormous amount of fear.
And all the way back to
what you talked about,
then this idea that we've got
to be driven in such a way
that that's going to
lead us to success.
And I think in a lot
of ways, it's not true.
But we believe it
and we buy into it.
So I appreciate
you bringing it up,
because that's a
very real-world one.
What else?
What else do you find makes
it difficult or challenging
to be compassionate
with yourself?
Yeah.
So denial.
So denying compassion
for ourselves,
that we're so
focused, we're just
moving on to whatever
the next thing is.
This idea, I don't need
that, who needs that, right?
Yeah, like what's
the value of it?
Well, you know it's interesting,
because as I started
to write this book, I didn't
know for sure exactly,
quite frankly, what the
book was going to be about,
which is always an
interesting thing.
Like, pitch the
publisher, it was
a new publisher on this
one, hey, what are you
gonna write a book about?
I don't really know yet,
we'll see what comes out.
But the idea was I knew I wanted
it to be about our relationship
with ourselves.
Because for me I have
always found, in my life--
and maybe you can
relate to this or not--
most of the things
that I attempt to do,
even the most challenging ones--
parenting, marriage, writing
a book, doing some of
the work that I do,
dealing with some
of the challenges.
I write a lot about in the
book of a lot of challenges
that I've faced in my life.
Most of those things
are relatively easy.
The hardest part, always, is
dealing with myself in relation
to those things.
Marriage-- actually,
my wife is fantastic.
My marriage is a piece
of cake except when
I'm being difficult about her
or about life or about whatever.
Parenting-- my
girls are fantastic.
They do whatever they do.
The hardest part of
parenting for me is me.
When I'm in my head,
oh, what are you doing?
You should spend
more time with them.
You should be like this,
you shouldn't be like that.
Stop doing that.
They're going to turn
out the wrong way.
Look, that other kid.
Whatever.
All that craziness,
that's all in my head.
So back to what's the
purpose, or what's
the point of self-compassion?
Well, I started to find--
there's a woman, actually,
who I've become friends with
now and really respect her work.
She's a professor at the
University of Texas in Austin.
Her name's Dr. Kristin
Neff, and she's
been studying self-compassion
for about a decade.
She's one of the world's leading
experts in self-compassion.
Some of you may be
familiar with her work.
If you're not, check her out.
She has a great Ted talk.
She's been researching
this and really
looking at-- in the same
way that Brene Brown has
been researching
vulnerability and shame
and other human emotions.
Some of you may be
familiar with her.
Kristin Neff's been
doing the same thing
with self-compassion.
So I had an opportunity
to talk to her
and actually interview
her, which was cool
because we recorded the
interview because I wanted
to keep it and share
it with people.
And here's what
she basically said.
She said look, as
a culture, here's
what we've done over the
last generation or two,
with good intentions, is we've
focused a lot on self-esteem.
The idea that people
have to have self-esteem.
Young people have
to have self-esteem,
we've got to have self esteem.
So we've raised a
generation, or generation
or two of young people, some
of you now in the workforce,
with this idea that
like, high self-esteem.
And that's good.
And she says the psychological
research shows us
that people who don't have high
self-esteem, major problems
can happen.
Depression, suicidal tendencies.
So having a certain level of
self-esteem is fundamental.
However, when we focus so
much on self-esteem, the way
that we've socialized
this idea of self esteem--
and every single one
of us in this room
and all of you
watching this video
can totally relate
to this-- we then
have our self-esteem be
a comparative process
about how we stack
up with other people.
It's a global evaluation of
our relative worth or value.
That's why when you show up
in an environment like Google,
just as an example, you may feel
good about yourself, but all
of a sudden, you don't
feel as good about yourself
because there's other
people around you.
And you say, I don't know
where I stack up in comparison
to these other people.
It's why a lot of people
in our Western culture,
particularly here in
the United States,
we have an enormous
amount of abundance
but we're constantly feeling
like we don't have enough.
You travel somewhere
else in the world
and realize, oh my goodness,
there's so much abundance
everywhere.
I just wasn't paying
attention, because
of the comparative nature.
So that's the negative, sort
of dark side of self-esteem.
Because the reality--and Kristin
talks about this, actually,
in her Ted talk-- but I
love when she says, look,
giving a talk, like
I'm giving a talk here.
If you came up to me
after this and went,
hey Mike, that was very
average, I would be mortified.
Like oh gosh, average is awful.
But if you think about
it statistically,
we're mostly going to be
average at most things we do.
But that seems like a bad thing.
And we're obsessed
with this idea
that we have to
be above average,
we have to be
exceptional at things.
And if we're not exceptional
then we're not good enough.
So you see how it
becomes a trap.
Self-esteem becomes a trap
because it's an insatiable,
never-ending--
Self-compassion,
on the other hand,
very different than self-esteem.
Self-compassion has
three components to it.
First of all a sense of
awareness or mindfulness.
Not denial.
How am I relating to myself?
What am I thinking, what am
I feeling, what's going on?
It's a core element of
emotional intelligence,
but it's a real core
element self-compassion.
What's going on?
The self-talk.
Most of us-- look, they
say the average human
being has between 50 or 60,000
separate thoughts every day,
and on average, 80%
of those thoughts
are negative or critical.
And if you're anything like me,
the majority of your thoughts
focus on yourself,
so guess what,
we're having 80% negative
thoughts about ourselves
every day.
And that's a really
important conversation
that we're having in our head
about ourselves all day long.
And often it's very critical.
So the first thing is just
noticing it, being aware of it.
The second thing is bringing
a sense of kindness.
And we all know how to
bring a sense of kindness
and compassion.
Think of someone you love.
Think of even like a child
or an animal, especially
someone that you're not-- have
a big ego connection with.
Sometimes with our
significant other
it can be positive or
negative, you know what I mean?
But just someone--
we know how to bring
kindness and compassion.
You see someone on the
street or someone who's
having a tough time,
we'll show up, right?
Tragedies happen in
our world, people
show up with an enormous amount
of compassion and kindness
for strangers, because it's
part of human nature, part
of our human spirit, right?
The question is, do we do that
to ourselves, or for ourselves?
And often we don't.
How do you react when you fail?
How do you react when
you get negative feedback
from your manager, from a
co-worker, from a friend?
You mess something up, you
hurt someone's feelings.
How do you treat yourself
in those moments?
And oftentimes we're
incredibly hard on ourselves.
One of the stories
I share in the book,
actually-- I was on my way
to Dublin to deliver a couple
sessions at the Google
office in Dublin.
This was a couple years
ago, end of I think 2012.
And I showed up at
the airport, SFO,
and I get in line for my flight.
And I'm about an
hour and a half, hour
and 45-- pretty
good for me, early.
It's an international
flight, so I'm there.
And then I realize, oh my
gosh, I forgot my passport.
And it's a Sunday.
And we were living in
San Rafael at the time.
And my home office-- I mean,
it's literally, the passport
sits right by my
phone in my office.
It's always there because
I can't forget my passport
when I'm going in--
I forgot my passport.
So I run up to the
front and I say to them,
I don't have my passport, can
I still get on the flight?
No.
I'm trying to talk to them,
someone has to bring it.
So I call my wife, Michelle,
who's at home with the girls.
It's a Sunday, we had some
friends staying with us.
And I'm in a panic.
Babe, I forgot my passport,
can you rush-- you know,
and they basically tell me,
she has to be here in an hour.
You have to have your
passport and everything.
We can check you in.
If it's past, closer than
an hour before the flight,
you can't get on.
So it's racing, racing,
Michelle's trying to do it,
get the girls handled, the
whole thing, gets to SFO,
gets me the passport.
But it's 45 minutes
before the flight,
and before she even gets
there I'm told by them
I'm not going to be able
to get on the flight.
And I am mortified.
And the voice in my head is
just going to town on me.
Because I'm thinking of some
of the annoying conversations
I've had with my wife about
certain things like not
itemizing a receipt from
Costco or whatever, right?
And here I am, like--
And I then find
out I will probably
be able to get on another
flight and get to Dublin just
in time for my event, but it's
going to cost me like $1,300
to do so on my dime.
And it completely-- as we call
in sports, an unforced error,
like it didn't need
to happen, right?
And like the little
gremlin in my head is like,
you idiot, what
is wrong with you?
You've been doing this for a
long time, you know better.
By the time my wife showed
up, I was literally in tears
when I went out
to give her a hug.
She was not upset
with me, actually.
She was incredibly
kind and compassionate.
She knew how upset I was.
And I got so upset, literally,
by the time I got to Dublin,
I was actually sick,
physically sick.
But for me it was actually
a great wake-up call
because I realized, wow, I
don't respond so well when
I make a mistake, especially
when I think it's a big one
and it shouldn't have
happened and all that stuff.
That's the way that little
gremlin, that little voice,
works, right?
So self-compassion is
awareness, kindness.
Can we be kind to ourselves?
And the third piece, and
this is really important,
is a sense of common humanity.
We're not the only one.
Back to the impostor syndrome.
When you start to feel
insecure here, or in your life,
or you show up
somewhere and think,
how did I get invited to this?
Or am I cut out for this?
Or you get a new job.
You ever have that happen?
You get a promotion, you're
all excited and proud,
and then you're like, oh gosh,
I don't know if I'm prepared,
I don't know if I can do this.
Whatever.
Have not only awareness
and kindness for yourself,
but then a sense of
oh, you know what,
this is part of being human.
And when we do that,
all of a sudden
it makes it less
personal, and we
can be not so attached to it.
Oh, I'm just having
this human reaction.
That make sense?
So that's the difference.
And nothing wrong
with self-esteem.
Nothing wrong with wanting us
to have confidence in ourselves,
but we so obsessed with,
I have to be exceptional,
I have to be above average.
We set ourselves up.
And then we never quite achieve.
Back to what you
were talking about,
this idea that I have to keep
pushing and driving and pushing
and driving, and then
it's never quite enough.
And sadly it takes, often
sometimes something tragic
or something really painful to
happen to slow us down and go,
you know what, maybe
I had things not quite
in perspective.
So what else?
Other thoughts you have about
this idea of self compassion,
either what makes it
difficult, or just,
even as I'm going through this,
any questions you have as I'm
talking about it.Yeah.
So the idea that
being indulgent,
or someone might judge me.
Oh, if I'm going to
be compassionate--
because now you're starting
to talk a bit about self care,
how do we honor and
take care of ourselves?
What do I need?
I need to take a little
extra time in the morning,
I'm going to go
get a massage, I'm
going to do certain things
to manage my wellness.
And then other people
might perceive it either
as being selfish or indulgent,
or who do you think you are?
And look, there is a
balance at some level.
Look, we're in
relationship with people.
Personally we're in relationship
with people at work.
Your manager or your boss says,
you have to get this to me,
and here's the deadline.
It's like, well, that doesn't
really feel good to me.
That may be a true response.
The manager might come
back and say, I'm sorry,
it still has to be
done by this time.
So we have to negotiate
it to some degree.
But here's the thing that we do,
and especially in our culture
these days, is that we
have this notion that
not doing that is
somehow heroic,
and doing that is
somehow selfish.
I remember years
ago, a mentor of mine
said this great thing to me.
He said Mike, one of the most
selfish things you can do
is be miserable.
I went, what do you mean?
He said, look, if
you're miserable,
everybody in your life who cares
about you worries about you.
So it's really important
to take care of yourself.
Focus on yourself, not to be
self-absorbed and unaware,
but actually
there's that balance
between the better we care for
ourselves, the more available
we are for other people.
My wife and I have had to
navigate this quite a bit
over the last eight
years, having kids.
We've got an eight-year-old
and a five-year-old.
I'm on the road
traveling, doing my work,
she's at home with the girls.
And there was a
whole bunch of stuff.
And we've been
together for 14 years
and have a great relationship,
communicate really openly,
really honestly.
But it was way harder
than we anticipated.
We didn't expect it
to be easy, but we
had no idea what we were in for.
And part of it, one of
the biggest challenges
for both of us,
especially for her,
is finding the
balance between how
do I go take care of
myself, and at the same time
show up for my girls
and for my husband
and for my life and
all those things?
And in fact, one of the
best things that we started
to do a few years
ago, was we each
will take time-- as busy as we
are with everything going on--
to go away by ourselves, not
only for our own mental health
and well-being.
It makes our marriage better.
It makes us better parents.
But we didn't learn that
until all of a sudden we got
so stressed out, so burned out,
so frustrated with each other,
with parenting, with life,
we just got to a point
where it was like, uncle.
We don't know what to do.
And that's a big piece
of self-compassion,
actually, is being
able to get to points
in your life in certain
places and say you know what?
Even though look, every single
one of you in this room,
everyone watching this video
or watching us on live stream,
you've had a certain
amount of success.
You've achieved certain
things in your life.
You're good at certain things.
That's fantastic.
But one of the ways you
get to that next level
isn't necessarily
by driving harder.
It's actually by being able
to put your hands up at times
and go, I have no idea
how to handle this.
I'm now out of my-- right?
And that's a good thing.
When you get out of
your comfort zone,
you get into a place
you're not used to,
you don't know how to
handle, that's fantastic.
That means you can grow.
But a lot of us, because we're
so worried about looking bad
and what people
will think, and I
don't like to sound like
an idiot or make mistakes,
we don't even let
ourselves go there.
I love what Brene
Brown talks about when
she talks about vulnerability.
It's a big part of
the work that I do.
And vulnerability--
she says look,
you can't get to courage without
walking through vulnerability.
That means it's going
to be uncomfortable.
So sometimes, even if
someone reacts negatively
when you say I'm gonna
take some extra time,
I'm going to go do this thing
that really nourishes me,
it's OK if they
react negatively.
And you might need to negotiate
a little bit with them.
But it's OK.
And the more we give ourselves
permission to do that,
the easier it gets for us.
And the more that we literally
train the people around us,
here's what's important
to me, and find out
what's important to them.
And the challenge is, especially
working in an environment
like here at Google, and
where most of us work
and how we work these days,
it's all day, 24/7 expectation
that you're going
to be on, connected,
communicating, and doing stuff.
And we have to manage
ourselves now more than ever,
so that we figure out
when we can unplug.
You know, I heard
someone awhile back
at a conference-- it was here
in Silicon Valley-- works
at another company here,
and he was saying look,
this whole idea of
it's a marathon,
not a sprint, he said,
doesn't fit for us.
We're sprinting all the time,
and we're not going to stop.
He said what we have
to learn how to do--
and this was a senior leader
in this organization--
is we have to learn
how to train people
and teach people and make
the environment conducive so
that we're taking pauses.
As Rachel knows, working
on a book on that, right?
Pauses in the midst of the
sprinting, if you will.
And that's at work, but
that's also in life.
Because again, we're
all walking around now
with our whole life, work
and otherwise, in our pocket
or in our purse.
Literally, it's there.
And if we want to we could
focus on that 24/7 and still not
get anywhere close to
caught up with everything.
That make sense?
So other thoughts
or other questions
or comments about this.
Yeah.
So the idea that I
have so much work
to do that it's selfish
to sit here for an hour
and listen to me talk and
have this conversation.
Well yeah, and then figure
out the balance of that.
Look, we all have stuff to do.
A friend of mine posted
something on Facebook
that I saw this
morning and it said,
I had all these things
to do yesterday--
she's similar to me, writes
and has her own business--
and she said, but
I decided-- and she
had a picture of her garden--
I decided to do this instead.
The idea being,
whatever it is-- we
all have jobs and
responsibilities
and commitments and
people expecting things--
we've got to manage that
to whatever degree we can.
But now more than ever, I
think it's more important
that we take some time for
ourselves and figure out,
what do I need to
nourish myself?
The G-Pause program, which
I don't know the specifics
about it, but you guys
can talk more about it.
But one of things I
gotta say, and you guys
know this, any of you
who've worked anywhere else
outside of Google-- there's
a lot of cool stuff going on
here.
It's not perfect
and utopia, right?
Every place has its challenges.
But there's such
a commitment here
in a way that's
pretty extraordinary.
And I have been-- for 14 years
I've been traveling around.
I live here in the Bay Area,
but I travel around the country
and at times around the world
speaking to and working inside
of organizations.
There's a genuine commitment
here by a lot of people
at a pretty high level
to focus on wellness,
to focus on well-being, to focus
on mindfulness and pausing.
And at the same
time, you guys are
an incredibly driven,
focused organization
that's very
metric-driven, and you've
got numbers and quotas
and goals and things
you got to accomplish.
So right here, it's the perfect
dichotomy of our culture.
There's a commitment
to wellness,
there's a commitment to
pausing, to slowing down.
And there's an enormous
commitment and pressure
to continue to
succeed and achieve
at the incredibly high level.
But think of that
at a meta level.
What happens here at Google
is just like in our lives.
And then the question
becomes, can we
listen to those multiple voices
inside of us and be the one,
as my own sort of
personal coach counselor
likes to say to me, all the
different voices in your head,
you've got to be the
chairman of the board.
You've got to say,
no, no, I'm in charge,
and literally then make
decisions and choices that best
serve you.
One of the things
about the book--
I wrote it in
short essay format,
so there's 40 short essays.
So it's literally like you can
just kind of open it up or read
the Table of Contents
and go, that's
the message that I need
about forgiving myself.
Or that's one that would
be really great for me
about vulnerability.
Or whatever.
But it actually made it
really fun and easy to write.
Which one of the things I had
to deal with as I was writing
this book was it was way
easier than my first two,
and I realized how committed
to struggling and suffering I
am at times.
Literally.
Like I was talking to my coach
and she was saying to me, Mike,
you think that for
something to be valuable
it has to really be hard.
You have to sweat and
it has to be difficult
and you have to suffer.
And she was like, maybe
you could give that up.
And I was like, but, really?
And I really had to
look at that, that so
much of my life, the thing,
the story becomes well,
you know, I don't know
what I was afraid of,
but people are going
to come in and go,
your life's been
really easy. no, no.
Let me tell you all the hard
things I've gone through.
Or, that was really
easy for you.
Like it was somehow
some badge of courage
to suffer and struggle.
So that's one piece.
But there's-- one of
the chapters I write,
I tell the story in there about
this game that I play with
my girls.
And the chapter is
called "Remember
That You're Valuable
Just Because You're You."
And here's the
way the game goes,
and I started playing
this game with my girls
a couple years ago.
Remember, they're
eight and five.
I think they were probably
like six and three or something
when I first started to do it.
And we do this all the
time, almost daily.
I'll say to one of my girls-- I
try to do it with each of them
but individually.
I'll say-- Samantha's eight,
Rosie's five-- I'll say,
hey Rosie, how much
does Daddy love you?
And she goes like this.
This much.
Sometimes she's laying in her
bed, so she goes, this much,
and it's pretty cute.
And I say, that's right.
And then I ask a really
important question.
I say, how come Daddy
loves you so much?
And you know what she says?
Because I'm me.
And I say, that's right,
honey, just because you're you.
And look, here's the deal.
I do it for them,
absolutely, because I
want them to get the message for
me, especially as young as they
are, especially as girls,
that I don't just love them
because they're
cute, I don't just
love them when they kick
a goal in the soccer game,
I don't just love
them when they listen
or when the teacher says
something nice about them
in class, all that stuff.
I love them no
matter what, and I
want them to get that message.
But I say it for
myself for two reasons.
First of all, as a
parent, because I
gotta remind myself--
even as young as they are
and as sweet as they
are at this age--
there are times it's hard for
me when they're doing things
that I don't like.
It's hard for me not to react
really harshly and really
negatively.
And even though part of
my job is to train them
and to parent them and to have
boundaries and all that stuff,
I don't want them to think
that it's conditional
based on their behavior.
And I'm going to have
to probably continue
to remind myself as
they get older, right?
But the second reason that I
do it is very personal for me,
because I still need that
message all the time,
that I'm not just valuable
because I wrote a book
or because I'm speaking
here at Google,
or whatever the accomplishments,
achievements of my life may be.
And the achievements
and the accomplishments
in my life, they're
important to me, absolutely.
But it's really important for
me to continue to remind myself
that that's not who I am.
And it's hard.
Any one of you in this room, any
one of you watching this video
or watching is on
live stream-- when
you've achieved and accomplished
certain things in your life,
or you're in an
environment that's really
focused on achievement
or a culture that's
focused on achievement like we
are-- it's hard not to assume
that my happiness
and my fulfillment
lies in some achievement
that I've yet to achieve yet.
It's out there somewhere.
I'll get there and then I'll--
but we've all learned the hard
way, it doesn't work that way.
It doesn't matter how
great the achievement is.
And sometimes the hardest part
about achieving something great
is that hollow
feeling we have after,
when we realize
oh, you know what?
That actually didn't
fill the hole in me
that I thought it was going to.
And instead of really looking at
that and going deeper into that
and saying, how do I
make peace with myself,
we erroneously then think, oh
no, it's another achievement.
And that one wasn't good enough,
that one wasn't big enough,
it'll be the next one and the
next one and the next one.
And if we keep on that path
it literally never ends.
And for better or
worse-- and you guys
have been creating some
of this technology--
we're sharing all kinds
of things with each other
all the time.
So now we get to deal with
the cesspool of comparison.
It happens all day,
every day, as we
check what other people
are doing and bragging
about on social
media and otherwise,
which then can bring us
right back down to like,
well, I'm not good enough.
And it's a trap.
Make sense?
So before we go
on-- I want to see
if you have questions or
thoughts about this-- turn
back to your partner.
Some of you have come in
since we paired up before.
Pair up with someone.
And again, if you're
watching the live stream,
you can write down if you're
not with another person
or watching the video.
But just, how does all of this
what I'm talking about so far,
how does this relate
to you specifically?
Where are there pieces of
this where it's like, oh,
I can see that in my life?
I'll give you a
minute just to talk
with each other about that.
And then I'll see if there's
some questions I can answer.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MIKE ROBBINS: Thoughts?
Anything anybody
wants to ask or share
about what we're
talking about here?
Yeah.
So the mechanisms
for sort of dealing
with the guilt when I
take time for myself.
That's a good question.
I think-- I'm a talker by
nature, it's what I do, right?
So I think communicating
and talking
is a really important thing.
So acknowledging it
if I'm feeling guilty.
And usually the places
where I tend to feel guilty
are with my wife and my girls,
because again, I'm on the road
and that poses a
challenge in my life.
I'm away from my family more
than I'd ultimately like to be.
And then when on
top of it I say,
hey babe, I really need to go
up Calistoga for a couple days,
Napa, whatever.
Sometimes some guilt and-- but
then we'll talk about that,
and I'll say, I
feel really guilty.
And then we'll communicate,
and sometimes it's
a negotiation a bit
about what's going
to work, what's not going to
work, where the impact is.
The other place where
I tend to feel guilty,
because relationships
and connections are
so important to me-- but
as my life has gotten
bigger and busier and I'm doing
more things both professionally
and then with my
family, I don't get
to connect with and see a
lot of my friends and people
I care about a lot.
So that poses a challenge.
But again, to me it's
about communicating
that, not like an excuse,
but just being real about it.
Instead of pretending,
because for a long time
I would do the thing
like, hey, yeah, great,
we should get
together, all right?
You know, all that BS
stuff that but we do.
Because really what I
was feeling is like,
gosh, I don't know
how to manage my life
and all my relationships
and connections.
And now, look, again, with
all the great technology
and all the way we're
now more interconnected,
there's just more people in
my sphere than used to be,
and I'm sure that's
true for most of us.
And then the question becomes
the level of authenticity
and the real connection
of those relationships.
So it's a challenge
to some degree,
but I also think the more
real we are about it,
people can understand.
And even again, talking
from that perspective
of-- sometimes
when I'm concerned,
if I'm going to do
something that might seem
selfish or self-absorbed or I'm
worried someone might judge me,
I will often just bring that up.
But not like a
critique, but more just
like from that
vulnerable place of like,
here's what I really want
to do, but I'm afraid
if I do that, you're
going to think this
or it's going to be a
problem or whatever.
So then we talk about it.
Does that make sense?
And you know, I had
another mentor of mine
say this great thing to
me a couple years back.
He said, you know, Mike,
what stands between you
and the kind of
relationships you really
want to have with people?
And I said, what's that?
And he said, probably a
ten-minute sweaty palm
conversation you're
too afraid to have.
He said, you get really good
at those ten-minute sweaty palm
conversations, you'll have
fantastic relationships.
He said, but if you avoid
them like most people do,
things will be tricky.
And you hope you roll the dice
and get really cool people
to work with and
really cool people
in your family, whatever, but
that's not usually the way
it works out naturally.
So that make sense?
Other questions.
AUDIENCE: So
building off of that,
can you talk about
some tips for when
wanting to be a
certain way and do
these things is in
conflict with the culture,
specifically to work.
MIKE ROBBINS: The environment.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So, for example,
if your environment is
we value putting
in a lot of hours,
and you know I am at my best
when I take care of my health
and when I'm sleeping right
and doing all those things.
And having those
conversations may
be tough to shift the culture.
Can you talk about that?
MIKE ROBBINS: Yeah.
I think, look, I think
it's a real challenge.
And guys here at Google
and a lot of people
working in intense environments
can relate to this.
Even people like myself who
have our own businesses,
it's not that
someone outside of me
is demanding that, it's
literally like, taking time off
at times means business
might not happen, right?
And so it doesn't
matter where we are,
but if the environment
doesn't seem
like it's conducive for
that, or we celebrate,
hey, you know, John was
working all weekend, great!
And it's like, OK.
Or the expectation
is, stay late,
get here early, all that stuff.
One thing is
communicating, just again
from that authentic place,
not like how it should be,
because that's a judgment,
but how it is for me.
Here's what I know
I really need.
And then figuring out if what
I need and what works for me
is going to work
in the environment.
And sometimes the hard
reality is, it's not.
It doesn't mean you're
bad or they're bad.
It just means, wow,
I'm either going
to have to inauthentically
abide by these norms-- and look,
we do this all the time in life.
So this doesn't make us
a terrible, weak person,
like, I'm gonna do that.
But be real about it with
ourselves first, and even
with other people.
But a lot of times there's
more wiggle room in negotiation
than we think.
One of my favorite
sayings is, the answer's
always no if you don't ask.
So we make assumptions
about stuff
that may or may not be true.
So that's the first thing.
The second thing
is-- I think it's
really important-- boundaries.
Having clear and clean
boundaries does not
mean that we're
righteous about them
or they're etched in stone.
But not having boundaries
creates problems down the road
because people take
advantage of us,
people do things that don't work
for us, we don't say anything,
and then we finally
do, we get pissed.
And then it's a problem
for them and for us.
And all of a sudden, whoa.
Think about conflicts that have
arisen at work about something
that you knew it was an
issue for a long time,
you just didn't say anything.
And then you finally
said something
and it has all this anger
and animosity behind it
because you've been holding
onto it for three months.
You know what I mean?
So it can be tricky.
And at the end of the
day, you have a boss,
you have an employer.
There are rules,
there are norms,
there are things that
we got to abide by.
If we're going to play that game
we gotta play by those rules.
I played baseball, right?
Even if I really felt like it,
you can't run to third base
first, you have to
run to first base
first because that's
the rules of that game.
And I could argue
all I want, but it's
more comfortable for me to
go that way than this way,
and they'd say, sorry,
Mike, you're out.
You don't get to play.
So there is some
balance of that.
And then the other thing is,
I think now more than ever,
there's a lot of things
happening in our culture
where we're finding--
there's a lot of research
out there-- Arianna Huffington
just wrote a great book called
"Thrive" that some of you may be
familiar with, where she talks
specifically about the
importance of sleep-- it's
probably the main
crux of that book,
sleep, take care
yourself, meditate,
take care of your inner life.
And she tells the story of
collapsing in her office
and literally hitting her head
on the desk on the way down
as she was launching
the Huffington Post.
And she ends up on the
floor in a pool of blood.
And she says-- and I've
seen her speak about this
and maybe some of
you have as well--
she goes, look, by every
conventional measure I
was successful.
But by any sane
definition of success,
when you're laying on your
office on a pool of blood,
you're not successful with the
way you're living your life,
right?
So the idea is that
this actually is going
to create--and some of you,
especially here at Google,
you're young enough,
you're healthy enough,
you can get by doing it,
but the reality is it's not
sustainable.
And I think again
organizationally,
people understand
that here at Google,
and even your own
manager or your own team,
start to make some agreements.
How do we get the work done,
and how do we do it in a way
that people aren't
fried in the process?
Because everyone's
dealing with that.
And at the very least start
to have the conversation,
to be open to are
there different ways
we could work and communicate?
Are there different ways
we could keep hours?
I don't know.
And depending on your
role and your team,
and sometimes there's
deadlines or there's
products or things-focused,
it's going to ebb and flow.
But I think there's
a lot more discussion
we can have about
it, and there's
a lot of science and research
backing up the importance of it
on our physical well-being and
then on our productivity level.
Arianna just did an
interview with Oprah
on "Super Soul Sunday", and
they were both talking about,
as two very, very successful
people, two things that came up
in that interview I
thought were interesting.
They were talking about
burnout, and Oprah
was saying, if you work one
of those crazy, long, 14-hour
days, you know those
last couple hours
you're not very productive.
It's just impossible.
But the other
thing-- Arianna said
one of the questions
she gets, and Oprah
mentioned someone
said this to her
when she knew she was
going to have Arianna
on-- oh, yeah, easy for you
guys to say sleep eight hours
and take care of yourself.
Now you're Oprah Winfrey
and Arianna Huffington.
Like, how did you get there?
But they both said that
actually some of the biggest
regrets they had in their
lives and their careers were
the times they worked
too much, and they
had things out of
balance and out of-- it
wasn't ultimately sustainable
and didn't lead them
to where they got to.
Now most of us
aren't at that level
and probably won't
get to that level.
But all of us have busy
lives and lots to manage.
And so in terms of
how you influence
the environment around
you, you communicate,
you model it, and see
if you can engage.
That make sense?
AUDIENCE: Maybe you can to talk
a little bit about-- so you
said that I think
in our culture we're
very used to this idea that,
like, no pain, no gain.
So unless it's you know,
things of great worth
take great effort,
unless it's painful,
we don't actually
get what we want.
And you said that with your
third book, that you kind of
had this revelation of
like, wow, this is easy.
Tell us a little bit about
how you worked through that
and how that could be
applicable for people like us.
MIKE ROBBINS: So how
it could be easy.
Yeah, I mean I first had
to confront the fact that I
was really attached to
suffering and struggling.
And that had been
for most of my life.
And look, it's not like
I have this figured out.
I mean in the process of
this, that part of my-- look,
I mean one of the
things as an athlete--
you know, we all have a
story about ourselves.
Some parts of it are really
heroic and wonderful,
some parts aren't so much.
We constantly need to revisit
that story and realize A,
it's not true.
We keep making it up and
the more we tell the story,
the more real it becomes.
But part of my story has
been, I'm a scrapper.
I'm kind of a scrappy guy.
Like I'm barely six feet tall.
I was a left-handed pitcher.
So this started in
baseball for me.
I wasn't the most
physically talented guy,
but there were very
few guys I ever
played with who worked
harder than I did.
And I got a lot of
positive feedback.
Look at Robbins, he's
always going the extra mile.
Look at Robbins, he's staying
after practice, way to go.
And for me it was like,
OK, that's one of the ways.
I wasn't blessed to
be six foot five.
I couldn't throw
95 miles an hour.
And as I started to
get better in baseball,
I realized that hard work--or
this is what I made up and was
told-- Robbins, you're going
to have to just keep grinding
hard.
OK.
I could do that.
Because I could control that.
My effort level I could control.
I couldn't always
control my talent level.
I got what I got.
And I couldn't
control the outcome.
In baseball-- even if you
don't follow baseball,
one of the things
about baseball,
it is filled with an
enormous amount of failure.
It is a game-- the best
hitters in baseball
get out seven out of 10 times.
It's a lot of failure.
I was a pitcher.
And pitching, and
some of you heard
me tell-- pitching is
awful in lot of ways.
Because you know what happens
to a pitcher in a game
when the pitcher
doesn't do well?
They literally stop the
game and take you out.
Can you imagine if you're
having a rough day at work,
you mess something up, and
literally your manager bursts
in the door or pops up on
your screen and says, you.
Leave.
And you have to walk out
and some other person
starts doing your work for you.
It's pretty humiliating.
So a lot of failure in baseball.
But I worked really
hard, worked really hard,
worked really hard.
When I got into my business--
I start my business
at 26 years old.
Now back in 2000-2001 when I
started my business as a coach
and wanting to be
an author, it was
starting to be a
bigger industry.
But there was no social media,
there was no blog world.
The only ways people
went about doing
that was you had to
go through pretty
conventional, traditional
ways to do it.
Hope to write a book, get some
notoriety, get on some TV show
or whatever.
And it was like, I'm
going to work really hard,
I'm going to hustle.
So all of that to say,
that's kind of in my DNA.
And there are some
positive sides to that.
It's not like I want
to throw that all out.
But I think the process
for me has been looking at,
who the people
that I know-- this
is a big thing, modeling
other people-- who
are the people that I know that
look like they're able to make
things happen with a
minimal amount of effort.
Because people like that, it's
like there's pixie dust on them
somehow and everything
they touch turns to gold?
That is actually a
conscious, deliberate thing,
whether they're fully aware
of what they're doing or not.
And I started to
realize, I think
I want a little more of that.
And I'll share this with you,
just because in the context--
I didn't write a book.
I wrote my first book
'07, my second book '09.
"Focus on the Good Stuff"
came out in '07, "Be Yourself"
came out on '09.
And we had two babies
and I wrote two books
in the span of three years.
I didn't sleep much,
I wasn't very healthy,
I wasn't very happy.
The end of 2009-- and I write
a lot about this in the book.
Michelle and I both.
I literally looked at her
one day and said, hey babe,
I got an idea.
How about we stop focusing
so much of our attention
on trying to look
happy and successful
and actually be
happy and successful?
Because I bet if
we actually are,
we'll probably look like it too.
Because here we
were in this life
that we thought we wanted,
with kids and I was doing work,
it was all great.
But underneath we
were stressed out.
We were tired.
We were in debt.
Things weren't how
we wanted them to be.
So when I started to think
about writing the next book,
I didn't even know what it was
going to be about, but I said,
I don't know what it's
going to be about,
but it's going to be a much
more pleasurable experience
to write.
And it took me many
years to finally
get ready to be in a place
where I could do that.
Lots of ups and downs in life.
But things started
to go well and I
started to feel like,
OK, I can do this.
When I finally sat down to
write this book last summer--
I have a tendency sometimes
to procrastinate on things.
And of you ever do that?
Big deadline.
But I finally committed,
I'm going to do this.
I wrote the book in seven weeks.
Now I kind of had to
because it was due, right?
But it was actually 17
days of writing, that's it.
I use Dragon speech
recognition software
because I'm such more of a
talker than I am a writer.
But you know what,
for the longest time
I thought that was cheating.
Can't really talk a
book, you gotta write it.
It's got to be hard, right?
And I share that
with you because what
happened for me is I started to
realize, it's OK if it's easy.
I don't have to
apologize for that.
So for a lot of us-- look,
nothing wrong with hard work.
I'm not saying
that's a bad thing.
But this idea that we have
to suffer and struggle
and things have to be
hard-- I'm now to the point
where my new practice in
life is, if it's too hard,
I'm actually going
to rethink about
do I really want to do it.
Or as a friend of
mine used to say to me
all the time, just because you
can doesn't mean you should.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We all have
had successes in life.
But some of my best
successes felt really easy,
and when people would actually
congratulate me, I would like,
just-- I wouldn't accept--
internally I wouldn't accept it
and I'd be like,
oh, that was easy.
So how do we get
over, how do we--
MIKE ROBBINS: I think
we take a lot of things
for granted about ourselves,
some of our strengths, some
of our gifts and things
that do come easy.
And I would really challenge
all of us not to do that,
to really be grateful for
the things that come easy.
And then ask ourselves
a deeper question,
less about the outcome and
more about the experience.
Is this what I want?
And if it does come
easy, be grateful
and feel blessed that it does.
Say thank you to
whatever you believe in.
Thank you.
This is easy for me.
And be mindful of the fact that
it's not easy for everybody.
So without bragging about it
or being arrogant about it,
it's like, wow.
Something for me.
I speak.
I've worked at this.
But this actually is
really easy for me.
And it's taken me awhile--
wow, wow, you're good at that.
I've done it a lot,
that makes it easier.
But I was born with a certain
gift, that this is what I do.
This is how I express myself.
So that's OK.
Then we focus on the
things that don't, and then
we spend a lot of
time thinking, I've
got to improve those things.
So it's big one.
Now let me say
this, because we've
got to wrap this
up, just time-wise.
I'll stick around for
those of you who are here
if you've got questions,
you want to chat with me.
Happy to talk to you.
Those of you on the video
or on the live stream,
we can stay in touch
just through my website,
mike-robbins.com.
But I want to close
with one last story just
to kind of bring
this all full circle,
because one of the key
things for us in all of this
is perspective.
I wrote this book primarily
about perspective,
perspective in my own life.
And one of the things-- and many
of you sitting here in the room
have the book itself-- but
I write a bit in the book
about an experience
that was really
poignant in my life over
these last few years,
and that's the death of my mom.
So my mom died in 2011.
And what was interesting
about that experience--
and any of you who've
lost people close
have probably had
this experience.
Really painful,
really difficult,
but incredibly growth-inducing,
and actually quite beautiful,
even in the midst of
the pain and sadness.
And one of the most poignant
moments for me-- my mom got
diagnosed with lung cancer in
March and she died in June,
so it happened pretty quickly.
And in some ways that
was actually a blessing.
But she knew it was
going to happen,
and she really surrendered.
And my mom was tough.
My mom was like, single
mom, raised two kids,
we grew up in Oakland.
You couldn't mess with my mom,
she was that kind of woman.
But towards the end she
really started to surrender
and she really
started to open up.
And we had beautiful
conversations,
and there was
amazing healings that
happened in our
relationship and our family.
It was just-- now none of
us wanted it to happen,
so it was really sad and
painful on many levels.
But it was such a
beautiful experience.
And there was a morning I got
up--it was probably about,
I don't know, a
month and a half,
two months before she died-- but
we knew, OK, this is serious,
we know where this is going.
There wasn't thought of--
it happened even quicker
than we thought.
So I'm on this run.
I had spent the night at my
childhood home in Oakland.
A lot of emotion.
I get up that morning,
I go for a run.
And I'm thinking in
my mind about my mom
and the whole situation
and I think to myself,
I wonder what it's like
for my mother right now,
knowing that she's going to die?
What would that feel like?
What would that be like?
And as I'm having that thought
I literally stopped running
and I went, wait a minute.
I know I'm going to die.
I just don't know when.
But I don't live like that.
I live with this
erroneous notion
of certainty, like I know
what's going to happen,
like I know my girls
are going to grow up,
and my wife, and this,
and I'm going to do this,
and I have all these
plans and these goals.
And those things are all
really important to me.
But I stopped and
went, wait a second.
What if I started to live
my life in a healthy way,
in an empowering way, from
that perspective of knowing
I'm not going to
be here forever.
None of us are going
to be here forever.
Everybody we're
in a relationship
with, everything we're
doing, everything here,
as extraordinary as this place
is, Google, it's temporary.
It's not permanent.
And if we can remember that,
and hold life-- hold our goals
and our dreams and
our relationships,
and even the things that
are most important to us--
with an open hand, with
a sense of intention
but not grasping so hard to
it, that all of a sudden,
a lot of the stuff that we worry
about and that we stress about
and that we get
upset about, it just
doesn't matter in
the face of that.
And that's one of
the many blessings
that I got from that
very painful experience.
And if we start to live our
lives from that perspective,
and look around
and realize we're
the common denominator in
every relationship we have
and everything we do.
And when we can
shift internally,
be more kind and compassionate
and loving towards ourselves,
keep things in perspective,
then everyone and everything
we interact with
literally changes.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]